المنتخب السعودي قدم اداء متميز جدا هذا
يعتبر الدائره المنتخب السعودي وفوت على
الارجنتين ااا
شو يعني مصر بكره القدم بسبب منتخب
السعودي ثبت جدارته تهنئه خاصه لشعبنا
والشقه ان السعوديين ونهن انفسنا ايضا
بهذا الفوز وان شاء الله كل الفوز عربي
احب ابارك باسمي وباسم الشعب العراقي
للشعب السعودي والمنتخب السعودي على هذا
الفوز الكبير احنا نعرف كل زين منتخب
الارجنتين ومنتخب جدا كبير وخاصه ليونيل
ميسي اخسر سبع مرات الكره الذهبيه فهمم
هذا يحسب للكره العربيه بالذات حاجه جميله
جدا وانا فرحان بصراحه للشعب السعودي
وبحقيق على اللعب اللعب النهارده ويا ريت
همم يفضل كده طول المونديال يعني منتخب
محترم كلنا كنا متوقعين بصراحه لماتش
هيبقى صعب عليهم والارجنتين تكسب بس همم
هم شرفوا العرب النهارده
خرافي عالمي
لارجنتين ولا غيره تقدر على السعوديه
ودائم السعودي فوق فوق وهمته هم الجبل
طويق الحمد لله على السعوديه محفوظه مبروك
مبروك مبروك مبروك
السعوديه تستاهل تستاهل تكون في القمه اي
فريق عربي اي انجاز عربي هذا يمثل الكل
يمثل الفرحه للجميع العرب فخور جدا
بانه الفريق السعودي غلب الارجنتين اللي
في ميسي اللي بيقولوا انه ميسي
بيرفع راس كل العرب والف الف مبروك
للمنتخب الاخضر وان شاء الله دايما يتم
مرافع راسنا هو المنتخبات العربيه كلها يا
رب يعني بستحق الفوز لعبوا بجداره فاز
بجداره اول مره نشعر فيه مباراه حقيقيه
فوز السعوديه اليوم فوز مهم جدا رفع من
قيمه ومعنويات الشباب العربي بشكل عام
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لعبت اليوم يعني
بشكل جميل جدا هناك انجاز تاريخي وسجل
حقيقه لصالح المملكه العربيه السعوديه
لكل الدول العربيه طبعا احنا مع السعوديه
ومع كل الدول العربيه ومن شدهم طبعا شيء
بيرفع الراس المنتخب السعودي الف الف
مبروك للاخوه في السعوديه ومنتخب ممتاز
يقع عاليه قوه واضح جدا في خطه واضحه في
ثبات في المستوى الف مبروك وان شاء الله
بنشوفهم في الادوار القادمه